Pope Francis condemned surrogacy he's
not just talking about IVF here which is
totally condemned and unacceptable
according to Catholic teaching he's not
just talking about certain kinds of
surrogacy uh homosexual couples renting
out a womb which is a phrase that Pope
Francis uses uterus for rent uh it's not
not even just that it's not just you
know the commercialization it's all of
it Pope Francis says I deem deplorable
the practice of so-called surrogate
motherhood which presents a grave
violation of the Dignity of the woman
and the child based on the exploitation
of situations of the mother's material
needs but Francis goes on to say child
is a gift end quote never the basis of a
commercial contract and he is called for
a global ban on surrogacy quote to
prohibit this practice universally to
prohibit what he calls quote uterus for
rent totally totally right here